bro have you ever done one of those um
salt enemas no eddie bravo you ever do a
salt anime drink about a bunch of warm
water coffee and that back when i when i
got stem cells but i don't mean up the
ass enema
there's a better bunch of salt water no
why if you drink salt water
dude when you have that much salt in
water you shouldn't you you were just
[ __ ] it's like you know one of them
things that just like jumps up when the
t's ready
yeah it's all crazy your [ __ ] just
goes wee
you guys ever do coffee enemas no i've
never done anything up my butt other
than one doctor apparently that's a
doctor go three three three three
fingers knuckle deep
i had one doctor pancake ask me
questions why is his finger in my
butthole yeah me too
hey can we do this one at a time we
pressed for time here son my doctor had
some [ __ ] bratwurst fingers too man
3d
makes sense at my age too to get it done
i got moles what did he say to you
afterwards you're good
you're young to be hit your crosstalk
check bro i'm telling you you're super
young
looks good